our president Trump's wounds is
self-inflicted the continuing
controversy over whether he's treating
the gold star families properly Plus
questions about Niger and the worst
anti-trump op-ed in The New York Times I
have ever seen we'll talk about all of
it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show besides you have to say
this is Charles blow op-ed in The New
York Times it's not just one of the war
stop ads about Trump I've ever seen it's
one of the worst written op eds about
Trump I've ever seen I want to go
through it at length because I think
that it reveals something about where
the blind spot is for the left with
regard to President Trump at first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at link so you don't know anything
about wine you're ignorant about wine
but you have to go over to somebody's
house for dinner and you want to bring a
good bottle of wine that isn't gonna
cost you a fortune
this is why you need to go over to my
friends at wink winc they make it easy
to discover great wine that's because
they have wine experts who select rinds
match to your taste personalized for you
shipped right to your door starting just
13 bucks a bottle there is nothing like
coming home to a delicious box of wink
wine that's selected just for you it is
the best day of your month and if you'd
want a bottle of wine this curated to
your taste or the taste of the people
you're bringing a bottle of wine over to
then you need to go over there and you
need to take their personalized survey
it asks you what foods you like and
that's what your palate is like and then
it personalizes a wine recommendation
just for you each month there are new
delicious wines like the insanely
popular summer water rose a no
membership fees skip any month cancel
anytime
shipping is complimentary and if you
don't like a bottle they send you they
will replace it with a bottle you love
no questions asked so discover great
wine today go to try winked calm / bend
that's try wink that's try winc dot-com
/ bend and you get $20 off your first
shipment if it's $20 off your first
shipment which means basically you're
gonna get at least one bottle of wine
without paying for it since each bottle
of wine is about $13 so that means try
winked calm / pending get $20 off your
first shipment again try winked calm /
Ben check it out makes you look like you
know what you're doing with wine plus it
tastes really good everybody in the
office is constantly drunk on wink wine
that is not a coincidence is both
because we hire an inordinate number of
alcoholics and also because wink wine is
really good okay so I want to start off
with this piece from Charles blow
was trending on Twitter this morning and
what was actually trending on Twitter
was Trump isn't Hitler right Trump isn't
Hitler so I clicked on that because I
was like wow somebody figured it out and
then it says Trump isn't Hitler but he
lies but the lying right that's the
actual title of it so he isn't like
Hitler but he's kind of like him except
for the mustache that's pretty much
where Charles blow over at the New York
Times is going now what's astonishing
about Charles blow is not just that he's
a bad thinker the New York Times op-ed
page as Andrew Clavin is fond of saying
a form of newspaper there op-ed pages we
have criticized in the last week is full
of people who are shoddy thinkers the
real problem with the New York Times
op-ed page with Charles blow is the
Charles blow is a shoddy writer I mean
he's just a bad writer I'm gonna read
you some of the stuff from this column
and you're going to see this is stuff
that would not pass you through Freshman
Seminar at a public college I mean this
is really not high-level stuff so but
Charles blow begins it is a commonly
accepted rule among those who are in the
business of argument especially online
that he or she who invokes Adolf Hitler
either an oratory or essays
automatically forfeits the argument oh
don't worry he's gonna do it anyway as
the reference is deemed far too extreme
too explosive too far beyond rational
correlation no matter how bad a
present-day politician now one of them
has charted or is charting a course to
exterminate millions of innocent people
as an active ethnic cleansing
Hitler stands alone in this regard but
but there are strategies that Hitler
used to secure power and rise things
that allowed his murderous reign they
can teach us about political theory and
practice and very reasonable and sage
comparisons can be drawn between
Hitler's strategies and those of others
so now if he's going to make a
reasonable and sage comparison what
exactly is his reasonable and sage
comparison it's that Hitler was a liar
and so is Donald J aid off Trump he says
one of those lessons is about how
purposeful lying can be effectively used
as propaganda the forthcoming comparison
isn't to Hitler the murderer at a Hitler
the liar now it's always weird to use
Hitler as an example of anything other
than mass murder well I actually am NOT
somebody who believes you can never make
Hitler comparisons I agree actually with
Charles blow that it is sometimes
worthwhile to look at how dictators rise
to power not using Hitler is the only
example looking at people like Mussolini
are looking at
like Franco looking at the various
dictators around the world and saying
how did they rise to power
Hitler's a particularly instructive
example because he rose to power in a
democracy right he was actually elected
to his position as Chancellor
essentially and it's fascinating to see
what he did in order to get there that's
why he's such an interesting character
historically at least with regard to
these sorts of comparisons but to boil
hitler down to the lire is again
historically ignorant this idea that
Hitler was the ultimate liar or that
Hitler teaches us all how lies work in
politics ignores that lies have worked
in politics for pretty much every
politician ever and Charles blow goes
further he brings out this old trope
that I'm not really fond of
I know dinesh d'souza called his book
the big lie there's this trope that goes
around it comes really from from
durables and our Gables and it comes
also from my income and it's the idea
that the big lie when used in politics
is the most effective that the bigger
you lied the more you get away with it I
don't think this is true I actually
don't think this is true I think that a
subtle lie repeated often is the one
that you get away with a lie that is
very difficult to verify is the one that
you get away with a big lie meaning like
an audacious lie which is usually how
people take it that's the one that's
easiest to debunk right they're turning
the frogs gay right relatively easy to
debunk how about pizza gate relatively
easy to debunk the Sun is green right
pretty easy to bunk we look up in the
sky it's not green we're done so the
bigger the lie in that sense the more
audacious the lie the easier it is to
debunk it is the subtle lie it is the
lie that that is is really a factor of
the person lying having more information
but not telling the truth than you and
you don't have enough information to
determine whether it's the truth or a
lie that's the why that's successful and
the more it's repeated the better it
does but what people on the Left can't
stand about Trump is that one of the
things one of the many things is that
Trump lies audaciously and says things
that aren't true all the time and people
don't seem to care and the left doesn't
understand why that is the left says
well why can't anyone just technologies
a liar yeah I cut a video during the
primaries Oh in in last year's election
cycle in which I explicitly said Donald
Trump is a liar he isn't mean Trump lies
a lot let's be frank about this Trump is
not an honest guy okay he does it
habitually he says a lot of things that
aren't true but I
the kind of damaging lies that destroy
the country right widget which are the
kind of lies that people worry more
about so in the exit polls this is where
Charles blow goes wrong ideologically
Charles blow suggests the American
people let trump get away with his lies
they believe him there is not a single
poll that has shown that Americans think
Trump is trustworthy in fact their polls
showing that people think CNN is more
trustworthy than Trump right now the
exit polls from 2016 an election that
Trump won showed that 64% of Americans
thought Trump was neither honest nor
trustworthy the same polls of course
showed that about the same number of
people thought Hitler did not Hitler
thought that Hillary was neither honest
nor trustworthy so that is the real
problem for the left not that Trump lies
and he gets away with it but a day why
two and the American public identify all
the lies and then they prefer the lives
of Donald Trump's in the lives of
Hillary Clinton right that's what's
actually going on in American politics
not the Trump lies and everybody goes
he's telling the truth
there's 30% of the population that does
that okay there are 30% of people who
will do that there's the bill Mitchell's
of the world so you say that everything
Trump says is gospel truth it is coming
down on high from Sinai it is absolutely
a hundred percent real but most people
most Americans look at Trump and they
say sometimes he tells the truth and
sometimes he tells truths that are
really necessary and sometimes he just
lies because he says crap or as I've
said many times on the show sometimes he
just says crap the Charles blow thinks
that the real reason Trump is winning is
because he is just such a skilled exact
razorsharp liar he's perfected the art
of lying he has figured out the hit
Larian tool and so he writes Trump is no
Hitler but the way he has manipulated
the American people with outrageous lies
stacked one on top of the other has an
eerie historical resonance demagogy has
a fixed design dong dong dong dong okay
what I would like to know are what were
the outrageous lies did he stab someone
on top of another the ones that he said
during the campaign the talking points
he said during the campaign that won him
victory were actually mostly true right
when he talked about how Hillary Clinton
was a criminal true when he talked about
Hillary Clinton being unfit for office
true when he said that people had to
vote for him if they wanted hope for the
court true right those were basically
true statements hey I may not have
believed them
but they but they were true I mean I
didn't believe the one about the court
because I have other issues with the
court but I think what he was saying was
at least if Ruud had had an element of
truth to it for sure the stuff that he
said that wasn't true during the
campaign and stuff about Ted Cruz's
father killing John F Kennedy and such
you know that kind of stuff people just
went yeah whatever they're willing to
overlook that because they felt like all
politicians lie now that is I think the
biggest lie that has been promulgated
and that's not Trump who said it it's
just it's something Americans believe
and I don't think it's true that all
politicians lie or have to lie but
that's something that's been pushed by
both sides of the aisle
it's cynicism masquerading as wisdom and
I don't think that it's really true in
any case Charles blow goes on in this
vein he says Trump has found a way to
couch the lies that people believe they
don't emanate from him but pass through
him he is not a producer but a projector
and then he talks about how Trump likes
to use phrases like lots of people that
are saying or I was told okay that's
true Trump does do that but then he
blows that up into and that's why Trump
is winning it's because of his lies and
only people could see through him if
only people could see the truth people
do see the truth and then they prefer
Trump to your guy what does that say
about your guy Charles well what does
that say about your movement that people
actually do see Trump relatively clearly
and then choose him anyway what does
that say about the left and that's a
question I think the left does not want
to cope with I do have to read you a
couple of paragraphs that are just
demonstrating that this this is really
one of the worst written columns I've
ever seen these two paragraphs are
astonishingly bad maybe I have crossed
the ink-stained line of the essay writer
where Hitler is always beyond it but I
don't think so ignoring what one of
history's greatest examples of lying has
to teach us about current examples of
lying particularly lying by the
president of the most powerful country
in the world seems to me an act of
timidity in a time of terror it is an
intentional self blinding to avoid
offending frail sensibilities I have
neither time nor patience for such
tiptoeing I prefer the best sentence
ever right here I prefer the boot of
truth to slam down to earth like thunder
no matter the shock of hearing its clap
there are no words for how bad that
writing is that writing is so intensely
awful I mean that writing is that that
should be like the purple writing
competition that they have every year
where they do like the worst sex scenes
maybe that should be in there it's not
even a sex sentence and it should be in
there it's so bad I prefer the boot of
truth to slam down-to-earth
like funder is like Bert Lahr from from
the from the Cowardly playing the
Cowardly Lion The Wizard of Oz like
blunder
no matter the shock of hearing its clap
okay first of all boots do not slam to
earth like thunder if they are sort of
fascistic image actually no matter the
shock of hearing its clap
there's no clap of a boot to earth I've
crossed the line from inks to ink stain
line of the essay writer I mean like
really the Freshman Seminar this would
been tossed out see - so bad stuff from
the nerd times the reason that I point
this out today is because Trump is under
assault and one of the questions we have
to ask ourselves to be honest observers
of the situation is whether Trump's
current political position he's in a bad
political position right now how much of
that is self-inflicted and how much of
that is because the media are out to get
him and I think it's a combination of
both I think that Trump has a penchant
for shooting himself in both feet and
then taking a knife and stabbing himself
in both feet and then taking a
sledgehammer and bashing himself in both
feet and then he hobbles around
complaining about the media I think the
media are more than happy to join in on
the fun I think the media are looking
for opportunities to do this so today's
case in point is the situation over in
Niger so if you missed what actually
happened it was easy to miss it because
the media didn't even cover it so on
October 4th there was a an Isis
apparently Isis attack in Niger okay and
this Isis attack in Niger killed four
Americans and in the I'm sorry he killed
four Americans and wounded another two
and in doing so it ended up basically
creating a firestorm because there are a
bunch of questions that have to be asked
about Niger now there's a Democrat named
Frederick Wilson and she is suggesting
that Niger is going to be trumps
Benghazi
here she is what no sir mr. Trump what
happened to me David in Nigeria
[Music]
why did it take hours for them to
discover him okay and there are all the
people clapping for that oh it's gonna
be as Benghazi so people are obviously
excited to make this Niger situation
into Trump's Benghazi
it is not clear it is really not clear
that there is anything here that says
that this is Trump's Benghazi here are
the questions that do have to be asked
about Niger okay there has some
questions that we need to ask about what
happened in Niger what happened in
Benghazi just to be clear was a failure
on every level there were six hundred
odd requests from people on the ground
in Libya to Hillary Clinton State
Department asking specifically for more
security turned down 600 odd times from
the State Department or ignored there
was an attack that took place over the
course of hours nobody arrived to help
afterward the administration openly lied
to the American public about it they
claimed that the American public was was
being told the truth they were not we
were told that it was an anti-islam
video that caused the problem that it
was not in fact the in organized terror
assault that was false and then we were
told in the aftermath of all of this
that everything had gone swimmingly and
that Hillary Clinton had done her job
and all the rest so there they're a
bunch of different issues that happen in
Benghazi that didn't necessarily happen
in Niger the Democrats are constantly
looking for something to be Trump's X
right so Russia is gonna be Trump's
Watergate ooh and then we get that that
the this situation is gonna be Trump's
at Benghazi whoo-hoo-hoo and then we get
the Puerto Rico is gonna be Trump's
Katrina woohoo it's always gonna be
Trump's something but we actually have
to determine whether it is one of these
things or whether it is not one of these
things there's not a lot of evidence to
suggest yet that Niger is trumps at
Benghazi now before I go any further and
ask the questions about Niger I first
want to stop and say thank you to our
sponsors over at Beachbody on
man so right now I'm on the road that
means that I don't have my personal
trainer that when I use at home it means
that I don't have lots of time to work
out and that's why I use Beachbody on
demand I don't have a lot of room in
this hotel room but that's enough room
for me to be able to workout and keep in
shape
they have all the best brands Beachbody
on demand we're talking about piyo or
talking about 21 day fix p90x insanity
three week yoga retreat all of these
familiar brands what Beachbody on demand
does is it gives you access to over 600
different workouts you don't have to get
bored enough to do the same routine
every single time it gives you
everything you need highly effective
world-class workouts you can do in your
home or on the road
plus extensive nutritional content all
this personalized to meet your needs
proven to help people achieve their
health and fitness goals Beachbody on
demand provides you the best in all of
this plus right now they even include
brand new first of their kind cooking
shows for healthy weight loss and
portion control
it's called fixate and that teaches you
how to cook healthy delicious simple
recipes for you and your family over a
hundred recipe videos there so if you
want to be in shape if you want to live
longer if you want to be happier the
best way to do it is Beachbody on demand
it's a brand new service it already has
over a million members your listeners
right now can claim a free trial
membership right Ben Shapiro listeners
we can claim a free trial membership
text Shapiro to 30 30 30 Shapiro to 30
30 30 and get full access to the entire
platform for free so go to your phone
right now I mean while you're listening
and just text the number 30 30 30 and
text the text Shapiro there and you get
a full trial access a free trial
membership to Beachbody on demand again
that gives you access to all of these
workout 600 different workouts all the
best workouts all the ones that you see
people on TV raving about you get all of
that and get to try it for free and see
whether you like it I promise you will
beach body on demand text Shapiro to 30
30 30 again Shapiro to 30 30 30 okay so
it is important at this point I think to
take a look at what was happening in
Niger so over in Niger a group of
American soldiers was reportedly
ambushed by 50 isis-affiliated fighters
that's what happened and in the process
of this ambush four American soldiers
were killed one of the American soldiers
who was killed was la David Johnson les
sergeant was David Johnson American hero
this is the person whose widow Trump
called the other day
and 'la David Johnson what was weird
about this
he got separated from the rest of the
troops and it took him 48 hours to find
him is it them 48 hours to find him so
this is where we start getting into
questions that do not have answers as of
yet terrorist groups use none so they're
a bunch of questions let's go through
the questions first of all why are we in
Niger in the first place so this is not
on Trump does not Obama Obama sent
troops to Niger in the first place the
idea was that our troops were going to
help quash Boko Haram in Nigeria and
neighboring countries like Chad that was
the idea here right neighboring
countries like Nigeria and Chad these
were countries where Boko Haram is very
active and so we were going to send 800
American troops in country that was
under Obama Trump just kept them there
the reason that that's a question is
because apparently we do not have
permission from the government of Niger
to actually drop ordnance in Niger so
one of the problems here is that about
30 minutes after this attack started
there were planes that arrived but they
didn't have permission to drop bombs
they're just doing flyovers of
terrorists which is insane it's insane
and there's a question to me as to why
exactly we are abiding by stupid rules
like that
what's knives we're gonna do toss us
from the country they need our help like
really what are they gonna do if we drop
a bomb and we kill a bunch of terrorists
so they launched a complaint big frickin
deal so that seems to me a serious
question second question why didn't we
know Isis was there so Isis is very
active in the region
Isis is is extraordinarily active in
Africa both northern Africa and
sub-saharan Africa and they use Niger as
a thoroughfare to move from northern
Africa to sub-saharan Africa the
Pentagon is still trying to figure out
why we didn't know that this ambush was
going to take place apparently a bunch
of our soldiers were there for a meeting
half of them were by the Humvees and
half of them were at the meeting on the
way on the way out of the meeting is
when the ambush took place this does
raise the question if it was an Isis
attack why the administration has not
openly acknowledged that it was an Isis
attack now that seems to me a real
question considering we're wondering why
didn't the Obama administration
acknowledge that al-qaeda was behind the
Benghazi attack the third question is
what exactly happened to sergeant
Johnson so according to CNN quote the US
military said it does not believe
Johnson ever fell into enemy hands but
had reason to believe he might be alive
military officials launched an urgent
search-and-rescue mission after
receiving electronic signals that
indicated Johnson might be alive in the
field which is just astonishing
his body was eventually found in a
nearby area but military investigators
do not know why he was left behind
during the French led evacuation and if
he was alive even for a short period of
time
US officials told CNN so we don't know
how he was killed there's gonna have to
be an investigation there we need to
know who I helped in Iraq sooner why
didn't the air cover arrive sooner there
was apparently a 30-minute delay and why
did it take trumped 112 days to
acknowledge the deaths so even though
this took place on October 4th and even
though the Pentagon had a statement
drafted that day Trump didn't say
anything on October 5th White House
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
said something in a press conference but
Trump himself didn't say anything until
last Monday Ryan knows last Monday that
Trump got himself in hot water so is
this a case of the media being out to
get Trump or is this a case of a
self-inflicted wound and the answer is a
little bit of both right Trump should
have acknowledged this earlier
Krum should have been forthcoming about
this I do not for the life of me
understand why any president isn't
forthcoming about the bad things that
happen the American people are very
forgiving when bad things happen and
presidents tell the truth they're very
unforgiving when bad things happen and
presidents lie to them Trump didn't lie
here but Trump should have acknowledged
this earlier obviously and then Trump
because he's defensive because he
defensive fellow who feels insulted all
the time instead of him saying listen
we're working on speaking with all the
families that's something that's got to
be done through proper channels instead
he said we've called everybody and I
don't think former presidents have
called everybody and that of course is
what launched the second firestorm right
and this again is half Trump and half
the media it's Trump's fault for
launching a thousand ships here it's
Trump's fault
for saying that Obama or Bush weren't
proper in their in their respect for for
the troops right that's it that's a
ridiculous statement Dana Perino has a
great piece out today talking about
President Bush going to Walter Reed
Hospital and visiting wounded soldiers
it's really moving I urge you to go read
it in full it's really terrific
apparently it's from her book it's an
excerpt from her book but it really is
quite moving the idea that bush or Obama
were disrespectful to those families
have fallen troops that is not true and
but but what the media did is instead of
just saying that's not true as I've been
saying for two days the media or three
days the media has decided instead it is
necessary and vital for them to go out
and say that Donald Trump actually
actively does not care about the troops
and so what they did is they decided to
go to end
down every family of every troop who's
been killed while Trump has been
president and then they decide that
they're going to make Trump look bad so
there's a gold star widow who was on CNN
saying you know Trump said he called
everybody he didn't call me at the
dignified transfer in Dover I was
extremely honored to have had vice
president pence there he spent a great
deal of time talking to me and it wasn't
it wasn't an uncomfortable type of thing
he really was just a very genuine human
being and he shared his condolences and
he talked to me like he knew me forever
so it meant a lot for me to have him
there
soon after maybe it was it was around
the same time I know that I was meeting
with my casualty officer and he received
a call from the White House I'm not
exactly sure who but he was told that I
needed to be by my phone for the next
few days because the president would be
calling me to express his condolences on
behalf of the nation and I just I never
received the phone call so the media of
course tracking all of these things down
now they didn't do this with Bush they
do this with Obama but because Trump
actually pushed the narrative that he
was the best of doing this now the media
saw an opening and they went for it
that's gross by the media it is okay
it's actually not really our business
whether Trump calls these troops
families or not at least not until the
troops families come out and speak about
it openly and ask Trump to do so there's
another story that came out from CNN
that during one of these calls Trump had
called the father of one of the soldiers
his divorce from the mother all of the
benefits I guess were supposed to go to
the mother and the father was
complaining about it so Trump said to
the father that he would cut him a
$25,000 check he then didn't do it for
months
CNN found this out and that day Trump
cut a check so CNN was saying well we
prompted Trump to cut the check okay
whatever whatever all of this is really
unseemly all this is really gross how
much of it is Trump how much of it is
the media I would say in this particular
circumstance about 40 percent of it is
Trump at about 60% of it as the media
Krum should not have opened this cat
this box of worms
instead he did and it turned into a
disaster area for him more on that in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Boleyn
branch so today I am in a hotel I've
been sleeping okay at the hotel but I
have not been sleeping as well as I do
at home
that is for several reasons but one of
those reasons for sure is the presence
of bull and branch sheets on my bed at
home there is no better
cheat in the world in ball and branch
eats again this is one of those products
where I have gone out and spent my own
money buying the product because it is
so good you think it's not necessary to
buy sheets that cost a little bit of
money you are wrong you are sleeping on
those things every night Boleyn branch
sheets their breathable they are
comfortable most comfortable sheets that
you have ever slept on they're the right
sheets they can take care sleep and your
style to the next level there are three
ex presidents and Bill Clinton's lovers
if he's one of them who sleep on bull
and branch sheets ball and branch sheets
are worth every penny what makes them
unique is that each sheet is crafted
from 100% organic cotton which means
they not only feel incredible they also
look amazing you know again I'm not any
sort of kind of sir when it comes to
sheets all I can tell you is what feels
good to me and bowl and branch is
fantastic and since they sell
exclusively online you don't pay the
expensive retail markups that's half the
price twice the quality you will love
them and you can try and risk-free 30
nights see for yourself you don't like
them return them for a full refund and
the reason they can afford to do that is
because everybody likes the sheets go to
Bowl and branch calm today you will get
$50 off your first set of sheets plus
free shipping when you use that promo
code Ben so go to bull and branch Bo LL
and branch calm use promo code Ben $50
off plus free shipping right now all and
branch calm again use that promo clip
and most comfortable sheets you will
ever sleep on okay so again the question
that we've been asking all podcast long
is whether this is Trump's fault the
current onslaught against Trump is
Trump's fault or whether it's the
media's fault and again the answer is
that it's mostly the media but Trump has
to not hit the trigger wire okay the
media basically are like a landmine and
Trump has to avoid stepping on as many
land mines as possible instead Trump has
a bad habit of seeing a landmine
grinning and then jump in with both feet
on top of it and so the media have of
course jumped on top of him with both
feet so Rob Reider you know it just
another example he comes out yesterday
he says well Trump is a sociopath right
he's a sociopath when it comes to the
treatment of our troops yes he has no
empathy
I mean he's I hate to say but he's a
sociopath I mean he has no feeling
it's one of thousands of things like
that when he talked about the conf em
Megan McCain who you had out he said
this is not a real hero because he got
captured I mean one thing after the next
I mean it's it's just a part of
everything that he's done well oh yeah
it's just a part of everything he's done
and of course the media love it they lap
it up the view there's big cheers from
the crowd and then they wonder why Trump
thinks that the media's out to get him
because the media are out to get him
no again some of this is Trump's phone
Sarah Huckabee Sanders came out today
and she said that the general Kelly
general John Kelly was disgusted by the
way all of this had been politicized
what will play Sanders and I'll explain
why Sanders is not completely correct to
do what she's doing here general Kelly
is disgusted by the way that this has
been politicized and that the focus has
become on the process and not the fact
that American lives were lost
I think he's disgusted and frustrated by
that if he has any anger it's towards
that
okay so again she's saying now the
general Kelly is is upset about it the
fact is general Kelly would not even be
part of the story except for the fact
that the White House trotted out general
Kelly as evidence that Obama didn't call
every soldier even though Obama sat next
to general Kelly in 2011 and 2012 after
the death of his son this is why I say a
lot of it's the media yes some of it is
President Trump he needs to do better
than this another example of this
there's a story that's happening right
now that is a very good story for Trump
and a very bad story for Democrats this
story is this it comes courtesy of the
it comes courtesy of Fox News it says
two top officials at the political
research firm behind it sorry
these autoplay videos are just terrible
it says two top officials behind the
fusion GPS dossier alleging various
Russian connections to president Trump's
campaign invoke their Fifth Amendment
right against self-incrimination before
the House Intelligence Committee on
Wednesday fusion GPS co-founder Peter
fridge top lieutenant Thomas Kattan or
subpoenaed to appear before the
committee in a closed-door session in a
closed-door session on Wednesday but
asserted their right not to testify a
source close to the matter told Fox News
Kattan took the fifth on every question
posed by committee members another
co-founder Glenn Simpson is under
subpoena for a later date the move was
expected so here's what happened here's
the backstory here the backstory is you
remember there was this dossier write a
Fusion GPS dossier compiled from a spine
and Christopher Steele over in Britain
fusion GPS is a democratic research firm
and they compiled this dossier which
ends up in the hands of the FBI and very
early in the Trump presidency there's a
story from BuzzFeed leaking this dossier
to the press the dossier had all of
these weird allegations about Trump some
have been substantiated some have not
the ones that have not are the most
ludicrous ones the ones about him being
peed on by Russian prostitutes and all
of this kind of weird stuff so fusion
GPS compiled this thing they've never
been called before Congress task
who asked you to compile this right who
paid you to compile this and the
officials of fusion GPS refused to say
now the obvious answers the Democrats
told fusion GPS to compile buzz right
that's the obvious answer there's
nothing illegal about that by the way as
far as I am aware I think the Democrats
just don't want to admit that they were
paying spies to come up with dirt on
Donald Trump so they've been trying to
stonewall it but as far as I'm aware
it's not against the law to hire an
intelligence official to spill his
secrets about president Trump it may
create some legal liability you know in
terms of in terms of like being sued but
I'm not sure that it does anything
beyond that in any case they took the
fifth this is an example of how a story
that is obviously good for Trump
Democrats probably targeting president
Trump through fusion GPS coming up with
bad data and then submitting it to the
FBI how President Trump is capable of
turning that into a story not about what
the story is about so Trump tweets out
something about the fusion GPS story and
and what he tweets out is this he tweets
out that quote workers a firm involved
with the discredited and faked dossier
take the fifth right who paid for it
Russia the FBI or the dens or all well
you know once you include the FBI and
Russia in there particularly you're now
basically accusing the FBI of being
traitors and that's not exactly the
attack you want to take now to be fair
to President Trump there have been
reports that the FBI wanted to pay
Christopher Steele to compile a dossier
in the past but they wouldn't use fusion
GPS to do it presumably
and I'm not aware that the FBI has ever
used fusion GPS as a thoroughfare to pay
some spy to come up with a dossier if
they want to pay somebody they should
pay somebody but you know now it's
president Trump challenging his own FBI
the media will jump on that it'll be
another bad story all right you know
this is not to say that president
Trump's twit Twitter feed can't be a
force for good like for example I think
Trump did the right thing when he
tweeted out about the Iranian story that
I discussed yesterday this is the story
that says that the Obama Department of
Justice knew full well that the Russians
were attempting corrupt activities and
they still allowed the State Department
to green-light uranium buying by the
Russian government so Trump tweeted this
out he tweeted out uranium deal to
Russia with Clinton help and Obama
administration knowledge is the biggest
story the fake media don't want to
follow that 100% is true and this is
where Trump's Twitter feed could be a
force for good right he can actually put
a spotlight but you have to put the
spotlight in the right place now that
tweet right there Trump allowed that to
be overshadowed by his other activities
if Trump could pick the right spot
if Trump could use the knife where the
knife is necessary instead of just kind
of waving it around like a crazy person
in an airport then his bully pulpit the
fact that he has this massive Twitter
following the fact that he can shift the
media's attention like that on a dime it
would actually be quite powerful imagine
if Trump tweeted one-tenth as much but
ten times as specifically how much more
effective would he be as president I'm
not saying get rid of the Twitter I'm
saying control yourself but if he can't
control himself get rid of the Twitter
this is a big story and it is a story
the media have been studiously avoiding
Eric Holder came out yesterday remember
this is Eric Holder's DOJ that approved
the Russian government buying twenty
percent of America's uranium they said
nothing right this day knew about it the
FBI knew about it the State Department
says they didn't know about it that's
probably a lie the State Department
probably knew about it the State
Department greenlit the deal anyway even
as Russia and especially as Russia was
pouring money into the Clinton
Foundation coffers Eric Holder who was
the head of that DOJ he's now coming out
saying he's a member of the resistance
and then we're supposed to wonder that
that Eric Holder is is is involved in
corrupt activities with other Democrats
it's been a difficult thing to watch and
it means that I think I have to be a
part of the resistance and to try to
save as much of the great work I think
that we did as is possible and to try to
ensure
that we put in place leadership 2018 in
2020 that will be supportive of the
positive things that we did you're my
brother resistance yeah yeah I am
there's is no question about that you
know I'm a progressive Democrat
committed to the ideals of my party and
proud of the work that I did is Attorney
General well as Attorney General you did
the work of a hack and he demonstrates
that full well and I'll show you in just
a second but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at quip so
there are a lot of recent studies that
say that if you do not brush your teeth
properly if your teeth are not properly
cleaned then it is linked to things like
heart disease okay this is why you need
to clean your teeth plus I mean you just
it looks horrible if you got broccoli in
there so please use quip quip is the new
company that is refreshing the way
people brush their teeth I can bring
this electronic toothbrush and this
electric toothbrush on the road impact
premium vibration and timer features
into a super slim design it's really
light enough to carry along a charger it
is self charging essentially you put a
battery in there and you're ready to go
it is half the cost of bulkier brushes
it is basically like Apple designed a
toothbrush but without that huge price
tag you should try it yourself you can
subscribe right now to receive new brush
heads on a dentist recommended three
month plan for just five bucks including
free shipping right now go to get quick
comm slash up hero get your first refill
pack clip starts like 25 bucks it's it's
much less expensive and then the ones
that you get over at the at the Rite Aid
or the CVS and it is also much better
than those ones because you can travel
with it because it is super slim it's a
nice looking toothbrush and you can
subscribe so that the heads are replaced
every so often right now go to get quip
comm slash Shapiro to get that first
refill pack 3 with the quip electric
toothbrush that is your first refill
pack absolutely free at get quip comm
slash apparel again that's a GE t qu IP
comm slash up hero get quip comm slash
up hero go over to get quip comm slash
Shapiro and check it out and keep your
teeth clean and and your health in order
okay so Eric holds our political hack
this is what I wish the media were
focused on if they weren't chasing
squirrels and Trump horns pushing them
to chase squirrels here's Eric Holder
suggesting that what James Comey did was
totally fine we talked about this
yesterday James Comey months before the
investigation had closed was already
getting ready to exonerate Hillary
Clinton there
holder of thing of course thinks that's
hunky-dory I've been critical of Jim
Comey but I've also known Jim coming for
you know 20 30 years he's an honest guy
and the determination that he made and I
think inappropriately announced I think
based on the facts based on his
interpretation of the law and there was
nothing more than that it was a good
faith assessment by a person who I think
has done a lot for us for this country
well I'm so glad that the partisan hack
that is Eric Holder thinks that a good
faith assessment was done Eric Holder
should be called before Congress he
should be asked to answer questions as
to why uranium deal is allowed to go
through with Hillary Clinton's
foundation receiving money at the exact
time he was head of the DOJ that seems
to me a major scandal that the media are
completely ignoring okay so last night
there was a big debate between Bernie
Sanders and Ted Cruz I also want to do
things I like in things I hate but first
we have to say goodbye to our friends
over at Facebook if you want to
subscribe then you can see the rest of
the show live which is just the best
thing we could possibly do $9.99 a month
gets you a subscription to daily
wired.com
you get my show live you get to be part
of my mailbag you get Andrew Clavin show
live you get you get michael Knowles's
show live god help us you get all of
those lives you get the people part of
our mail bags let me do conversations
live question conversations will answer
your questions and make your life better
plus you get the website all ad-free
a banner ad free and so you get all
those things for $9.99 a month for 99
bucks a year you get the annual
subscription which comes along with the
world-famous never duplicated never
defeated tumbler the the leftist here's
hot or cold tumbler
I don't even bring it on the road
because it is that valuable if the
airlines were to lose it then half of my
network would be gone it is that good
ninety nine dollars a year it gets you
that tumbler plus all of the
aforementioned glories available at
daily wire.com if you just want to
listen later for free go over to
SoundCloud or iTunes download the show
subscribe go over to youtube and
subscribe over there we have lots of
videos that come out and are just videos
that you won't get the ride tunes or
SoundCloud make sure you leave us a
review at all of these places we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you
so last night Bernie Sanders and Ted
Cruz debate on taxes
I will admit I did not watch this live I
was giving a speech over at University
of Tennessee I think that it's a speech
that you should go listen to and go
watch it's different than my normal
speech on college campuses I talked a
little bit about the meaning of life yes
really the meaning of life and why I
think our lack of meaning is leading us
down a dark path in the United States
where we are just clubbing the living
crap out of each other on a daily basis
but to people who are clubbing more than
Ted Cruz using his Zodiac killer knife
and Bernie Sanders using his Walker they
were they were doing it last night on
CNN on taxes it was about how you'd
expect it to go the I want to show you
one clip of a guy stumping Bernie
Sanders on taxes and doing something I
wish Ted Cruz had done but didn't last
night here is this this question are
stumping Bernie Sanders on taxes the
senator Sanders over my lifetime all
we've seen is more government and more
expenses cutting taxes from top to
bottom or bomb the top I review it then
will give some relief to the burden some
expenses all Americans face why would
you not want a tax cut across the board
for all Americans well I do want a tax
cut for the middle class and working
families but the Koch brothers should
get a tax break of up to 30 billion do
you think that makes sense I did say all
Americans well do you think that the
wealthy should not get tax breaks I did
say all Americans okay well I happen not
to believe that the Koch brothers need a
tax break is is very upset about that
and that's when the curb the enthusiasm
music starts in the Bernie did not get
his pudding cup the reason that I think
Republicans do this wrong is because I
think that if you watch Ted Cruz last
night he too was focusing on the middle
class and the lower classes need more
tax cuts okay let's be real about this
the people who need the tax cuts the
most in order to generate wealth in the
economy are the people who are paying
the taxes that is disproportionately
people at the top it is very hard to
give tax relief to people who are paying
very little in taxes I've done this tax
break down before so I don't see the
need to do it again the bottom line is
that if you are in the lowest quintile
of income earners in the United States
you're essentially paying zero taxes
when it comes to net taxes in the United
States meaning the benefits you get back
from government basically the only
people paying tax
in the United States net taxes in the
United States are people in the top ten
percent of income earners those are the
people who are actually generating the
jobs hey there's a weird misconception
about the economy and that is that every
dollar that is spent is equally helpful
to the generation of a healthy economy
this is untrue if I spend a dollar on a
hamburger that is not nearly as helpful
to the generation of a stronger economy
than if I spend that dollar investing in
hiring somebody to grow daily wire okay
the reason for that is because I'm
inventing new products and services over
at Daily wire right the reason that your
life is better now than it was 20 years
ago the reason you have cool new stuff
the reason you can go on a computer and
you can hit a button and stuff arrives
at your door the reason you can go to
all of our advertisers online and
arrives and order things that arrive at
your door right now is because people
were innovative because people created
new products and services it's not the
amount of money passing through the
economy that matters it's the products
that are being generated by the passage
of that money
ok income is a passive byproduct to the
generation of new products and services
like presumably you're happier right now
because you're watching this show if we
didn't have somebody investing in the
show namely you and also people who are
very wealthy who invested in the
creation of daily weiter you wouldn't
have that and this is true of every
product you own this is true of every
product you own Bill Gates has done more
to alleviate poverty than the federal
government hey that's just a fact of
life Kida the federal poverty rate is
basically the same as it was before the
war on poverty ever began bill Bill
Gates has created enormous numbers of
jobs across the economy and made
people's lives easier and better ok this
is certainly true of Jeff Bezos as well
everybody likes to complain about the
generation of new products because
whenever a new product is generated an
old product is is hurt but those new
products are what makes life better for
all of us
Amazon is better than having to go to a
used bookstore I love used bookstores ok
I miss used bookstores but Amazon is a
better service ok Amazon is a better
service for shopping then going to your
local grocery store very often it's
particularly true here in a place like
Manhattan where it's hard to schlep
groceries around ok the fact is that if
you actually want a better world you're
going to have to allow people who
generate new things to keep their money
and generate more new things ok because
it turns out that a lot of the people
who generate new things people like Elon
Musk they generate lots of new things
there's nothing to generate one new
thing and now they're done it's they
generate lots of
new things with that money or they give
to a bank and you know the bank does it
doesn't invest in hamburgers the bank
goes and invests in new businesses that
are starting up and generate better
products the reason your life is better
now than it was 50 years ago is not
because there are more more dollars
flowing through the economy precisely
the opposite it's the it's the idea that
the products that are being generated in
passing through the economy are simply
better they're just simply better okay
so now I want to talk about a couple of
things that I like and then a couple of
things that I hate so let's start with
some things that I like
so the first thing that I like is if I
had turned off my cell phone before the
show I mean the sound today just awful
but in any case the things that I like
okay so yesterday Ben Sasse was in a in
a meeting with Ted Cruz and Ben Sasse
decided that it was that it was
worthwhile to spill a dr. pepper on Ted
Cruz and this became kind of a viral
thing and then Ben Sasse tweeted
something at Ted Cruz about the idea
that Ted Cruz had his father had killed
JFK so Ted Cruz then sent back this
tweet which is just awesome
all right so Ben Sasse has full
disclosure I was wearing my Lee Harvey
Oswald was framed t-shirt and then Ted
Cruz tweeted back the Zodiac killer note
which set the internet aflame whereas
879 thousand likes 47,000 retweets very
funny stuff I don't know if Cruz himself
came up with that it's possible it is
also possible as an assistant but
whatever it is it's really really funny
you know this is why politicians ought
to embrace some of the memory on the
internet because some of its really
funny speaking of memory on the internet
I did have to laugh yesterday because
one of the things that was being passed
around the internet was a conspiracy
theory regarding Melania Trump no not
that she's some sort of Russian spy the
conspiracy theory is that Melania Trump
is a body double really really funny so
you can see this guy by legal meds calm
I assume he's a guy high on pot he says
this is not Melania to think they would
go this far and try and make us think
it's her on TV is mind blowing
mind blowing makes me wonder what else
is a lie and it shows a picture of
Melania Trump and then a close-up of
Melania Trump right and it is clearly
still Melania Trump he said let me save
you some time from looking it up it is
not her
okay dude it's her I do love when people
are so crazy and I also love the fact
that he misspelled Melania Trump in the
in the Google line there ml M il as
opposed to M L so pretty grand stuff
from the internet they're just proving
that people will believe anything this
was going around the internet the truth
is that it we know that it was Melania
Trump because she does have a body devil
but the body double was eating at comet
ping-pong pizza yesterday so it couldn't
have been her over there with Trump
other things that I like this is just
quite wonderful so Isis was defeated in
Raqqa as I discussed yesterday the
biggest untold story of the week it's
been obliterated by all of the stupid
news the
we have to cover but after Isis was
defeated in Raqqa this is video of one
of the women who was oppressed under
Isis so she took off her headscarf it's
just where it forced to wear that
headscarf and she took it off and she
and she threw it down
the liberation of human beings is
something the American military is quite
grand at and something left should
acknowledge because you know while
they'd say the president Trump
disrespects the military it's the it's
the American left that wanted to slash
the military and suggest that the
American military's a force for evil
around the world for decades now okay
time for a couple of quick things that I
hate so first of all Chelsea Handler man
I don't know why she thinks she's funny
I mean I guess because she's very
wealthy apparently somebody thinks she's
funny so I guess I'm in the minority
here or at least I am part of a silent
majority but she cancelled her Netflix
talk show cuz no one is watching it cuz
it was crap and instead she says she's
now going to focus on wait for it social
activism oh yeah so she wrote this on
Twitter like so many across the country
the past presidential election and the
countless events that have unfolded
since have galvanized me from the
national level downs of the grassroots
it's clear our decisions of the ballot
box next year will mark a defining
moment for our nation for these reasons
I've decided not to return for another
season of Chelsea and instead to vote as
much time as I can to becoming a more
knowledgeable and engaged citizen and to
focus on projects that may have
significance to me so first of all I
would recommend that you learn to read
The Cat in the Hat is always a great
starter book so it's fun with Dick and
Jane shows my goal is to be better
informed raise my voice and participate
in a more meaningful way I want to
travel the country visit areas and
people I don't know enough about speak
at colleges listen to students in a
better understanding of our political
divide I have joined forces with Emily's
list to elect more people to more
women's public office register people to
vote and campaign for candidates who are
fighting for women's rights oh it sounds
not like she wants to learn but more
like she wants to spread her particular
brand of stupid and a particular brand
of stupid is quite strong I wasn't sure
whether to put this in things I like
heard things I hate because there are a
couple things I like about it one
Chelsea Show will no longer be on
Netflix which is awesome and to Chelsea
out in the public eye is not bad for the
Republican Party for the conservative
movement or Donald Trump okay it's
actually quite good the more Hollywood
shows its face the more the rest of
America silently repels away and I think
that that's exactly right they're like
Homer Simpson in that in that Jeff you
know slowly backing into the bush I
think that's that's how Americans react
to Chelsea Handler so the more she's out
there the more
Americans are likely alienated from the
Democrats okay other things that I hate
today
so Mayim Bialik the star of The Big Bang
Theory one of the stars of the Big Bang
Theory long history in Hollywood she
wrote a piece about sexual harassment in
the New York Times and she just got an
enormous amount of crap for it why
because she suggested that if you want
to minimize section the chances that you
will be sexually harassed personally
then you might want to consider dressing
more modestly okay this is what she
actually wrote what she wrote is well
find the exact section here she says as
a nontraditional-looking woman I came
back to an industry that had me
auditioning for the frumpy friend or the
zaftig secretary though I eventually
landed a role that has earned me for I
mean nominations is it a surprise I
planned an androgynous awkward late
bloomer she says I've experienced the
upside of not being a perfect 10 is a
proud feminist with little desire to die
I get plastic surgery or hire a personal
trainer I have almost no personal
experience with men asking to meet me in
their hotel rooms those of us in
Hollywood who don't represent an
impossible standard of beauty have
luxury of being overlooked and in many
cases ignored by men in power unless we
can make the money I still make choices
every day this is the paragraph that
that drove the left insane I still make
choices every day as a 41 year old
actress that I think of as
self-protecting and wise I have decided
that my sexual self is best reserved for
private situations with those I'm most
intimate with I dress modestly I don't
act flirtatiously with men as a policy I
am entirely aware these types of choices
might feel oppressive too many young
feminists women should be able to wear
whatever they want they should be able
to flirt however they want with whomever
they want why are we the ones who have
to police our behavior in a perfect
world women should be free to act
however they want but our world isn't
perfect nothing absolutely nothing
excuses men for assaulting or abusing
women but we can't be naive about the
culture we live in I believe we can
change our culture but it won't be
something that happens overnight we live
in a society that has treated women as
disposable playmates for far longer than
mr. Weinstein has been meeting on Jews
and luxury hotel rooms so I don't see
what's wrong with anything that she's
writing here she's not saying that you
bear the responsibility for sexual
harassment or sexual assault if you
don't dress modestly and a guy does
something evil to you that's not what
she's saying what she is saying is the
same thing that I have said a thousand
times about conceal and carry right we
live in a violent world it behooves you
if you don't want to be violently
accosted to conceal and carry we live in
a violent world that's why you have a
lock on your front
or the I mean I honestly it does not
make it any better for somebody to open
your front door if it is unlocked it
doesn't justify somebody breaking into
your house if the front door is unlocked
it doesn't justify anybody shooting you
if you don't have a concealed carry
permit but if you can take measures to
prevent bad things from happening or
make it less likely they happen to you
why is that bad advice I'm confused why
that is bad advice if you can avoid bad
situations why wouldn't you and to
pretend they're not worse situations in
better situations is to ignore reality
of course there are worse situations in
better situations right that's exactly
what Mike Pence has his rules it's why I
have personal rules right though the
whole point here is to have rules that
that help minimize these situations so
yes men should be the ones who have the
burden of having the rules for the most
part but is it stupid to recognize the
reality that if you are dressed in a
more provocative fashion and you are
openly flirting with a bunch of guys it
is more likely that somebody is going to
sexually harass you Methos it again
justify the sexual harassment it's still
wrong just as it's still wrong for
somebody robbed my house if I leave the
door unlocked but it would be smarter
for me to lock the door it might be
smarter for you not to get drunk with
your coworkers and and dress
provocatively if you don't want to be
sexually harassed again that's it that
is not a justification I can't she says
it herself in this piece so the feminist
movement comes out oh so terrible Mayim
Bialik justifying sexual harassment
making saying the woman's are really the
victims are the provocateurs no that's
not what she's saying she's saying the
same thing that you would tell your
daughter hey you would tell your
daughter this you would feminist you
would tell your daughter myths and if
you wouldn't you're bad parent you're
bad parent hey you would tell your
daughter not to walk alone in a
dangerous neighborhood at night you
would as a feminist would you say the
world isn't fair you saying that my
daughter can't walk alone in a bad area
town were lots of crime occurs are you
saying it's her fault if she gets mugged
no I'm saying don't walk alone in a bad
part of town were lots of crime occurs
that's what I'm saying
that's all I'm saying that's all that
Mayim Bialik is saying and the fact that
things like modesty are considered not
preventative the things that thing the
fact that things like taking sex
seriously as opposed to just treating
sex as a throwaway disposable object but
that may actually minimize chances at
sexual assault and sexual harassment I
mean isn't this like just obvious
it is true if a woman decides to go up
to a room with a hotel room with a man
and then the man rapes her the rape is a
rape I mean I should go to jail be
castrated or killed
right I'm on board however as a matter
of as a matter of practicality would it
not be smarter for the woman not to go
up to the hotel room with the man in the
first place if she can avoid it is it
bad advice to say listen you can do
whatever you want it doesn't remove the
moral responsibility from the men or add
moral responsibility to you but just to
be smart when you want some risk
mitigation here our entire life is about
risk mitigation and pretending that it's
not is just blinding yourself to reality
so I it's really sickening to me what
they're doing Mayim Bialik just
ridiculous and demonstrates the scorn
that people have for religious people
Mayim Bialik is a quasi Orthodox Jew and
so she abides by certain rules of
modesty and it's so funny the
independent ran a piece like three days
ago saying that Islam was the solution
to sexual harassment and Mayim Bialik
basically says that simple
judeo-christian modesty might be a way
of minimizing opportunities for bad men
to sexually harass you and she's Luanne
raked over the coals amazing how that
worked ok so I was gonna do the big idea
today but I think that we may have run
out of time so we'll do it we'll do it
instead tomorrow maybe with the mailbag
we will be back home tomorrow so less
technical difficulties we apologize for
any technical difficulties you
experienced but we will be back home
from Tennessee tomorrow i am ben shapiro
this is the venture Pierrot show
[Music]